hi my name is Erin I use she her
pronouns and I'm
Reuben that's it no pronouns Dave Rubin
Reuben report February 27 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals as always share subscribe tap
that notification Bell and uh we've got
that post game show where you can add
comments you can ask me questions you
can correct factual errors or offer up
conspiracy theories at Ruben
report.locals.com uh we got a big show
for you today and right before we
started Connor well Phoenix said it was
a 9-8 Connor did you offer a counter to
that
because we've got a 9 8 he sent me on a
high bar on a Monday
9-2 wow Daphne
nine five all right
okay we'll see what happens uh we got a
big show for you I'm refreshed weekend
uh just so everybody knows because I'm
getting a lot of messages about it kids
and David feeling much much better by
the way I had said a couple times on the
show that the kids had covered so we
know that David had kovid the kids we
just believe had coveted because David
had coveted I did not stick anything up
their nose to figure it out it was
actually irrelevant but they were
snipply and Sneezy and nights were tough
and blah blah blah anyway everyone is
back to health it's all good around here
weather was great this weekend feeling
good and uh let's get to it I wanted to
frame the show today sort of around this
Woody Harrelson appearance on Saturday
Night Live Saturday Night Live which I
think debuted if I'm not mistaken in
1975 it's an old comedy program and it
used to be funny a long long time ago
actually when it debuted they used to
call them the not ready for Prime Time
Players because they were sort of out
there and Politically Incorrect and
funky and not polished and they didn't
have perfect teeth and perfect air and
all of those things that's why they put
them on late night you know 11 30 p.m on
Saturdays and it was live so it was
funky and weird and you never knew what
was going to happen over the course of
the last 40 years
it's had iterations where it's kind of
gone up and down in moments that were
really great and some that were terrible
but you know you had the Chevy Chase Dan
Aykroyd ears which obviously were great
then you go into the 80s and you've got
the Sandler years and David Spade which
were good and then you know little
things come and go that are good you had
uh Norm Macdonald was uh doing Weekend
Update and anyway it's become sort of
terrible how about that for the last say
10 years it's just left this drivel
nonsense corporate crap however in some
bizarre twist they put Woody Harrelson
on this past Saturday he's got a new
movie coming out so that's usually where
they get the guest host you know
promoting something they put him on and
he started talking about covid
and vaccines and cartels and government
and media and multinational corporations
and it was rather interesting that this
this was making its way onto corporate
television and really he actually was
prescribing some some answers to some of
the nonsense that we're kind of talking
about here all the time so let me show
you a quick little clip should we start
with a Quick Clip or we're gonna we're
gonna do an ad first we're gonna do an
ad first I want you people to eat well
before we get into anything coveted
related I want you to eat meat people
that's what we're talking about let me
talk to you about Mike real quick uh you
know that 60 of U.S pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day there's Better Way guys I want
to tell you about moink that's moo plus
oink Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door YouTube is the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts pork chops pork chops salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel any time there's nothing better
than cooking their meats on my green egg
on a Friday evening ain't it the truth
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted plus they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got mocked
keep American farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get a free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste
m-o-i-n-k-box.com reubenmoitbox.com
Reuben and now back to me all right so
we got a big show for you I want to get
to the clips quickly so here is a
initial snippet of Woody Harrelson on
NBC corporate press quote-unquote comedy
show Saturday Night Live okay so the
movie goes like this the biggest drug
cartels in the world get together and
buy up all the media and all the
politicians and force all the people in
the world stay locked in their homes and
people can only come out if they take
the cartels drugs and keep taking them
over and over
I threw the script away I mean who is
going to believe that crazy idea okay so
this is sort of interesting now Woody
Harrelson a well-known pot smoker right
so people think of him as just sort of
this out there Fringe figure but the
corporate press chose to put him on SNL
and then you know when they're writing
that monologue that is looked at not
only by the ep the executive producer of
SNL but you know someone at NBC
entertainment it works its way through
the lawyers it's going to get all the
way up like there's just no doubt that
the highest people at Rockefeller Center
in New York City they knew what he was
going to say so now the question is why
would they allow a monologue which
continued Way Beyond that why would they
allow for what we were told were
conspiracy theories and corporations
that were forcing us to be injected and
locked lock us in our homes and all of
the collusion that you know a bunch of
us crazy Fringe right Wingers were
talking about why would they be allowing
that on NBC now and there is a reason
for that I firmly believe there's a
reason for or that and what the reason
is is that enough of us have woke up
enough of us have gone from say woke to
awake and they're realizing they better
allow some level of something kinda true
on television before every single person
realizes what nonsensical BS it is so
it's nice that they put Woody Harrelson
out there to give this monologue you
could tell that the audience didn't know
what to make of it are we allowed to
laugh because they have to you know
there are a bunch of lefties they have
to look for approval over what's funny
they can't decide on their own so
they're not sure about that to some
degree I think you can argue they put
him on to do this because he's thought
of a fringe figure so it just makes the
ideas look Fringe but I really think
what I just said previously is the right
estimation which is that this is their
way of this is why the system basically
always is in charge why it always
manages to survive because somehow all
of us say things for a long time and
they block us and they silence us and
they cancel us and all of that stuff and
we're right-wing maniacs and conspiracy
theories theorists and we're
anti-vaxxers and then suddenly years
later they literally take our positions
right in front of our eyes and what do
we do I saw everyone on Twitter doing
this over the last couple days oh my God
it's so amazing SNL is doing the right
thing it's so great and it's like yeah
to some degree yeah but also you should
know the game that they are playing but
let's continue because Woody Harrelson
about six months ago was on it was right
before I was on he was on Bill Maher's
podcast the club random podcast and he
was talking while stoned about all of
the government and Pharma collusion
related to blocking cheap drugs here's
the CDC promoting that we have to do all
of these things right I just I don't
like profiteering in war you know think
of the billions of dollars that have
gone to Big Pharma but I was getting
back to my original point the last
people I would trust with my health
his big Pharma and big government
because neither one of those strike me
as caring entities spoken as the perfect
redneck hippie really if that message
doesn't I mean you know about profit
exactly you're all about profit and both
sides have seen the profit they've made
I think they've done a lot of studies
about vitamin D and how important it was
when the people who had low levels they
were much more
um
vulnerable to covid why not tell people
that can't you make money selling
vitamin D is it that kind of what's the
worst that could happen that's just it
man there was only one thing you know I
remember Mac didn't got made into a you
know horse tranquilizer uh a horse
whatever it is which it is but also used
by humans it would use my millions and
millions of years uh
hydroxychloroquine got uh made
ridiculous
um and there was only one thing that
could work and that's the vaccine right
and so ultimately because of that
billions of dollars was made so it's
interesting the reason I'm showing you
this is not to tell you that Woody
Harrelson is the biggest genius in the
world but isn't he laying out a lot more
truth than what you would get from
someone at CNN or the New York Times etc
etc right he's asking the right
questions and he's he's making it
personal I don't believe that big
government or big Pharma has my own
health in their interests they sort of
want us to be weak and unable to do
anything or think straight about things
and our immune systems compromise so
that we can always be on their drugs
Bill is doing a little bit of kind of
defending the system can't they make
money off Vitamin D well the thing is
you could just walk outside and get a
little sunshine and you'll get your
vitamin D but
as Woody went into further in the SNL uh
monologue uh he knew I think in essence
that the media was going to come for him
so now watch this so there there is a
guy I can actually call this guy a
journalist I don't know who he is he
goes by the uh the Twitter handle
kanekoa okay uh and he put together look
at this this is just wild uh so this is
after Woody Harrelson's SNL uh
appearance Woody Harrelson the biggest
drug cartels in the world got get
together and buy up all the media that
was an actual quote here are four
headlines that appeared immediately
after on Sunday yesterday these are four
mainstream Rolling Stone Daily Beast
huffpo variety headlines Rolling Stone
Woody Harrelson spreads anti-vaxx
conspiracies Daily Beast Woody Harrelson
spews anti-vaxx conspiracies in Rambling
SNL Monologue it's almost like they
coordinate this stuff Woody uh
Huffington Post Woody Harrelson Rambles
about weed anti-vax conspiracy Woody
Harrelson's SNL model makes covid
conspiracy jokes that were the one was
variety so they literally prove his
point right in front you guys get this I
don't know how they do it is it on a
list serve do they get it on an email a
memo are they in a secret group
somewhere I don't know how it happens
but anyone with like a roughly
approximately decent sense of what's
gone on in the world over the last
couple years would go Woody Harrelson's
not being completely conspiratorial he's
not being completely
anti-vaxx he's anti the way the covid
vaccine was laid out I don't know all of
his feelings on vaccinations but clearly
this is all about covid and the way they
then coordinate those headlines it is
rather incredible so I think at that
point once they once they start
coordinating this stuff I think we can
refer to the mainstream media as a
cartel they work in conjunction to take
out their enemies and Woody Harrelson is
definitely an enemy at the moment that
being said he is being let into the
system which is why NBC put him on so
they're telling you now what is what is
acceptable in the Overton window that's
the best way to describe it but we have
to continue to wake up to this nonsense
and one of the things that a lot of
people are waking up to right now is
that the lab leak Theory which a bunch
of crazy right-wing conspiracy theorists
were talking about two and a half years
ago or at least theorizing it might be
true because we knew that there was gain
of function research happening at this
Wuhan lab uh well now it's starting to
Bubble into the mainstream as well
because as I always tell you guys truth
is a Time release pill truth happens we
can't talk about Truth for a long time
and then that time release kicks in and
then suddenly we can go with the truth
here's the Wall Street Journal this
weekend just in U.S energy department
has concluded that the covid pandemic
most likely arose from a laboratory leak
according to a new classified
intelligence report well isn't that
something isn't that wild when crazy
people like me two years ago were going
I don't know exactly where it came from
but I'd be willing to at least entertain
that idea and if you were willing to
entertain that idea again you were
called all of the worst things in the
book you probably had your Twitter
account nuked or suspended Facebook
depressed you in the algorithm Etc et
cetera but now that we know that it
basically is true and we'll have more on
that in just a second how did the media
treat people who talked about the lab
leak for the last couple years here's a
couple headlines for you March 21 from
CNN lably coveted 19 theory is like
something out of a comic book virologist
says in February of 23 U.S energy
Department assesses covid-19 likely
resulted from Lab leak furthering U.S
Intel divide over virus Origins truth is
a Time release bill uh here is a
headline from CNN couple uh what was
this this one's about two years ago
nearly 30 percent in the U.S believe a
coronavirus Theory that's almost
certainly not true interesting turned
out to be true here's Vice news Trump's
Wuhan lab coronavirus conspiracy is
bogus according to uh everyone well not
uh today uh and then here this is this
is pretty good uh so there's uh the
editor and chief writer of the
Washington post's fact Checker unit and
anyone that works at something called a
fact Checker unit or is a misinformation
Specialist or a disinformation agent
they usually are just promoters of lies
and nonsense and always protecting the
machine so that's what this guy Glenn
Kessler is but once again his official
title is editor and chief writer of the
Washington post's fact checker
in 2020 in response to Ted Cruz saying
that the lab leak Theory might be real
this is what Glenn Kessler wrote I fear
Ted Cruz missed the scientific animation
in the video that shows how it is
virtually impossible for the virus to
jump from the lab or the many interviews
with actual scientists we deal in facts
and viewers can judge for themselves
because then Ted Cruz retweeted that
gave him a couple pinocchios a couple
pinocchios for Glenn because the point
is the Washington Post as he's
belittling Ted Cruz for not listening to
scientists and everything out it turns
out Ted Cruz was right Ted Cruz was by
the way just theorizing right he's
linking to an article and theorizing
this might be a lab leak why is it this
is the question why is it that the
machine was so hell-bent on none of us
thinking that it might be a lab leak
perhaps then it would it would be
because then we'd really have to think
about what our relationship with China
is right and was this a bio weapon and
was this intentional and did the NIH
found uh actually fund some of this
stuff which fauci under oath said that
we did not but we've got quite a segue
for you uh here is fauci contradicting
news reports that gain of function was
happening at the Wuhan lab uh funded by
the NIH we I I don't know how many times
I can say it Madam chair we did not fund
gain of function research to be
conducted in the Wuhan Institute of
virology
in our healthy we now know that a bat
coronavirus was enhanced in a lab NIH an
niaid
categorically has not funded gain of
function research to be conducted in the
Wuhan Institute the National Institutes
of Health acknowledged that it funded
research of a virus that was studied at
the Wuhan Institute of virology the
experiment unexpectedly we're told made
a bat coronavirus more contagious than
the original naturally occurring one Dr
fauci knowing that it is a crime to lie
to Congress do you wish to retract your
statement of May 11th where you claimed
that the NIH never funded gain of
function research in Wuhan
senator Paul I have never lied before
the Congress and I do not retract that
statement a new letter raising questions
about experiments in a Wuhan lab what
was let me finish take an animal virus
and you increase his responsibility to
humans right you're saying that's not
getting a function yeah that is correct
and and senator Paul you do not know
what you are talking about quite frankly
and I want to say that officially you do
not know what you are talking about
three years the National Institutes of
Health provided grant money to the Eco
Health Alliance research Group which
conducted experiments with that
coronaviruses in Beyond China okay so
you really got to understand what fauci
is doing here he's been caught everyone
gets it he's playing and I think this is
what he was doing under oath he's
playing some weird game whether the
nih-funded Eco health or how the money
got around or whether it was a mistake
or not and that's what his lawyers you
know once this really bubbles up further
as the truth is that time release bill
and more and more people look into this
and go man he really did lie on the
earth because NIH did fund gain of
function research they were looking into
this coronavirus and then they gain a
function you added a function to it you
add a function to a virus to make it
jump to human so it can either be used
as a bio weapon or so that
pharmaceutical companies can come in and
be like oh my God there's this crazy
virus out there we don't know where it
came from but you're not going to
believe this we have a vaccine for this
thing and it's just been sitting in the
chest over there it's wild we had it in
the basement on ice so he will will
absolutely play semantic games he was
playing semantic games right there and
this is where I keep saying to you guys
the the Republican party right now which
has been showing some teeth they've been
showing their balls I know I have to
come up with a better metaphor uh but
they have a chance now you have fouchy
under oath lying if Jake Tapper is
freaking saying that the NIH was funding
it
then at this point you know it's got to
be true because he had to be dragged to
the truth to say it so we know there is
something cooking here so the
Republicans now better go all right
fauci you lied to Congress and We Know
It by the way when I had Rand Paul on
I've had him on many times over the last
year at least three or four times uh I
think the last time I had him on he
repeatedly said that he knew and you
could tell by his reaction there he knew
that fauci was lying but this cartel
that we're talking about is not just a
covid cartel and they're not just gonna
beat you up over covid but it's also
going to be about the oncoming War
because there is an oncoming war and it
also is going to be about the value of
the US dollar because they are doing
everything they can to destroy that but
speaking of Destruction uh this Ukraine
Russia situation is is spinning out of
control incredibly fast uh let me for
the record because it's a Monday just
say I am not for War I would prefer not
to go into World War III uh I would
rather help the people of America in
East Palestine who are having some
problems because of a massive explosion
and chemicals in the water then
continuously giving money to Ukraine
with no receipts and having no freaking
idea what's going on over there but
somehow we do everything backwards here
right we the media is in it with the
politicians they really really want not
only to keep continue driving us to the
path towards War but to make sure that
if you somehow ask a question about that
you will be thought of as a Russian
stooge or a Putin operative or you're on
the take or something like that but here
let's listen to zielinski zelenski of
course is the president of Ukraine who
is now a hero he shows up to the Grammys
and the Oscars he meets with all the
presidents he demands things he gives
nothing in return you have to do what he
wants and here he is thanking American
journalists and a couple other people
but journalists for their uncritical
support of Ukraine
I would like to say
American
grass president the
TV uh channels the journalists
and everyone that has been supporting us
pretty good when you got the Congress
yeah they're writing the checks you got
the president yeah he's just a stooge
he'll do whatever you want because his
son was somehow involved in some major
corruption in Ukraine but you know we
weren't allowed to talk about that for a
couple years you got the TV channels and
the journalists boy it's almost like
you guys have the machine and you're
sending all sorts of money there with no
receipts attached so a whole bunch of
people can get rich on the war machine
it's almost like we've seen this script
before right I think we've seen this
script once or twice before say Iraq war
not that long ago about 20 years say
Afghanistan war not that long ago about
20 years lasted about 20 years
you guys got it but now watch zielinski
and this is just incredible it's the
tone that he he speaks in uh that really
drives me wild because you would think
that if your country remember it Kamala
Harris said it herself Russia big
Ukraine small so if your country was
being obliterated and blown apart and
all your people were being killed and
there was a massive Invasion and all of
this stuff you'd think well first off I
don't know how you have time to go to
the Grammys and everything else that
that seems like that would be low on the
list but okay maybe that's just me
um but you would think that when you're
out there communicating hey Ukraine
needs help that there would be some
level of
um
not decency that there would be some
level of contriteness relative to your
problem right you wouldn't be demanding
people uh do things you would be asking
people to do things you wouldn't be
making the case but oddly the case has
been made for him so all he has to do
out there is basically say give me money
and if you don't give me money uh some
really bad stuff is gonna happen it's
really wild listen to this one
and
I'm actually very happy that we have
bipartisan support but we keep hearing
those messages from time to time and
they're dangerous
uh there are political leaders that are
elected by people and if this issue is
raised those political leaders need to
be responsible and cautious because
people are looking at them who wants a
third world war would anyone
risk would anyone be willing to accept
that risk
Russia is going to enter
Baltic states NATO member states and
then the U.S will have to send their
sons and daughters exactly the same way
as we are sending their sons and
daughters to war and they will have to
fight because it's a nature that we're
talking about and they will be dying
guys if you don't do exactly what he
wants and really what he's trying to do
there is threaten Republican
presidential candidates if we get a new
Administration and they're less into
this Ukraine thing
and it's going to lead to World War he's
literally saying if you don't fund the
March towards War we're going to have
World War III that's what he's saying
most from what I would say are are sane
sober foreign policy experts
and just decent citizens of the United
States are going we have a lot of
problems here uh we are in massive debt
we're having crazy inflation the
president's got dementia a bunch of
problems here at the home front maybe we
can't just fund this thing endlessly and
then every two weeks Lindsey Graham or
some other clown comes out and says give
them 12 more planes and everyone votes
on it and take the planes and put some
cash on those planes right you can't
just give them a plane without any cash
people like you know it's like when you
win the jackpot you want like a fancy
car to show up and you open up the door
and there's a bunch of cash in there too
enough
enough but he's basically threatening us
and it seems odd again if you were the
guy that was on the brunt of this
horrific war and that is not a defense
of anything that Russia is doing
you would be a little more understanding
of the concerns of the average American
or the average person in any NATO
country who's going to foot the bill on
this and have their children go out
there
um
if we just stop let's put it this way
guys really think about it if we just
stopped right now if we just said hey
starting today actually we got in a
little over our heads uh we're going to
ease up on this war thing we're not
going to give you money for a little bit
let's see if maybe you guys can figure
it out and then maybe zelenski would
have to say oh I guess the endless war
machine and the war chest is running out
of money I'm running out of ammo uh
maybe I will have to negotiate with
Putin and maybe that's not the funnest
idea and maybe Putin is a completely bad
faith actor but do you think that gets
us closer or further away to war that
gets us clearly further away to war but
if we keep funding War he's telling us
the reverse of the truth if you don't
endlessly fund it endlessly give me the
guns the weapons and all that stuff
somehow that will end Us in World War
Three and I'm telling you guys for some
reason these wackadoodles would like to
take us to World War III I don't know if
they have a serious spiritual problem or
what's going on here but here is
National Security advisor Jake Sullivan
uh being asked about the potential of
world War III and if you think this is
going to make you feel comfortable I
have to do we have a warning this will
not make you feel comfortable warning we
don't have such a warning well I'm just
telling you guys this ain't gonna make
you feel comfortable
you level with the American people about
what expectations should be could there
still be a full-blown war going on a
year from now on the second anniversary
that the U.S is still supporting at the
levels it is now
I can level with the American people in
saying that war is unpredictable I
cannot predict the future and nor can
anyone else and anyone who is suggesting
they can Define for you how and when
this war will end is not leveling with
the American people or anyone else
I can predict the future I can predict
the future that's what you did there
dude uh that's a bit of a problem I get
that you can't predict the future you
can't predict the future we don't know
war is weird uh international relations
are weird but you must understand the
guiding principle of this government is
to continue this war
why is it just somebody please and no
one can ever explain it someone
explained to simple Dave Rubin via email
or
you can you know write in the locals
Community or in YouTube comments someone
explains a simple Dave Rubin
say Dave you're a simple man you don't
understand we have to give a hundred
billion dollars to this foreign country
to support their war effort and we can't
give 100th of that one billion dollars
to the people of East Palestine because
here are the reasons for some reason no
one will explain that why can't a
hundred of what we've given to this
foreign country that is demanding more
and more and more to continue a war that
we are now in it has not been declared
but we are at War make no mistake about
it we can't do any of that back home why
can't we because we are governed by
complete idiots here is Secretary of
State Anthony blinken on who's paying
for this and I think he's uh well he
kind of gets it right but I don't really
like this guy or how he says things
there's trying times in America for
people financially and oftentimes we
might sit back and hear about what's
happening in Ukraine and hear about the
money that U.S is pouring into Ukraine
um and the resources that we're pouring
into Ukraine why are we doing that for
those that are watching and asking that
same question so first uh taxpayers have
been incredibly generous and we have to
make sure that we're using their money
wisely in Ukraine
the taxpayers have been incredibly
genuine generous
have you guys did you get a call you
know I don't pick up spam calls so it's
possible I might have got a call from
the government and it just said spam so
I didn't pick it up and they were like
would you like to give your money to
Ukraine
we've been incredibly generous you guys
are stealing our money you are stealing
our money you're turning more people
into Libertarians any given day right
the average person that is paying any
level of attention right now is going
yeah taxation is theft because you're
taking our money to fund your adventure
so please do not pretend that we are
being generous you are a thief and a
criminal blinking that's what you are so
what does this all do then it gives a
great Avenue to a guy like Donald Trump
and this is where Donald Trump
absolutely excels Donald Trump excels
when it's talking directly to the people
about the evil sucking monster machine
and and this is what he did he went to
the ground he bited refused to go right
gay peep didn't go so Trump says I'm
going to East Palestine I'm showing up
at McDonald's I'm going to bring some
food and water and I'm going to talk to
the actual people there
what this community needs now are not
excuses and
all of the other things you've been
hearing but answers and results and
that's what I think you're going to say
say Norfolk Southern needs to fulfill
its responsibilities and obligations
and I see that they're starting to come
here now too because they also were
saying they're not coming
but it means that the affected
communities beyond the borders of East
Palestine Palestine are going to be
taken care of and they've said so and
they've said it loud and clear and I
think they probably mean it I sincerely
hope that when
your representatives and all of the
politicians get here including Biden
they get back from touring Ukraine
that he's got some money left over
because we're now at 117 billion dollars
and as you probably know Europe when you
add it all up is at about 10 billion
dollars that's a big difference wouldn't
you say
that's Trump at his best right that's
when he's with the people and the people
support him and he's standing up to the
machine and as he said 117 billion now
so now Biden has still not been there
I'm going to show you a clip on Biden
discussing this in just a second but why
is it that when gay Pete showed up two
days later after Trump and Trump got an
incredibly wonderful warm Ovation Pete
did not and he shows up in his little
hat and his vest and he pretends he
knows what he's doing and all of that
stuff and nobody's happy that he's there
why is it that he wasn't able to show up
with I don't know 20 million bucks
not 117 billion a lot of zeros but uh
how about 20 million bucks we're going
to help you guys figure this out but he
couldn't do that
very very curious and Biden has no plans
on going because he sent the EPA as if
the EPA does absolutely anything take a
look it's been three weeks now since the
toxic train derailment in East Palestine
Ohio as you know the mayor says he saw
you in Ukraine and he says it tells you
he doesn't care about us they're asking
is the President coming to Ohio
do you have any plan to travel to Ohio
and have you talked with the mayor yet
let's put this in perspective within two
hours
of that derailment the EPA was in there
within two hours
every major agency in the United States
government has had anything to do with
Rail and or cleanup was there and is
there
he's completely missing the point I
accept that the EPA was there I don't
know that the two-hour thing was right
and I certainly doubt that every agency
that would be involved in something of
this magnitude was there in two hours
but let's say they all got there within
24 hours I'm not even sure that's true
but I'll in this case I'm going to Grant
him a Long Leash on this one that's fine
and let's hope they're doing the
appropriate work I don't really think
that they are they're telling people
literally to drink the tap water
meanwhile JD Vance senator from Ohio is
out there with a stick in the river
showing that there's there is glowing
goo basically in the water that feeds 10
percent of the United States but let's
just assume Biden is telling you the
truth on all of that he's still missing
the point which is why don't you show up
that there are a good amount of people
in the United States of America who
think that you Joe Biden don't care
about America you care about spending
more time giving money to people
overseas for their Adventures rather
than just showing up just showing up so
this is a great opportunity for Trump he
took advantage of it I think Biden and
Pete and this whole administrator look
completely ridiculous but one of the
things that you also have to know and I
know you guys know this is that the
bigger issue here is that how this
information gets translated to the
people is always through a leftist lens
so here is CNN's John Avalon saying
comparing Trump going to East Palestine
and Biden going to Ukraine are just
complete BS everything basically
everything that I've just defended here
and laid out for you is just complete
nonsense you can't compare these two
things the criticizing Biden for being
overseas in Ukraine on the even the one
year anniversary and not being in Ohio
is a total false equivalence it's
complete BS
um and and you know you can do both and
you should do both and Biden should go
to that Community
um but the preeminent responsibility is
leading an International Coalition to
stop Uh Russian aggression and and to to
try to undercut that under the auspices
of America First and and photo ops at
McDonald's passing out branded water
isn't isn't a sufficient response as you
said it's personal for you your family
is from there and uh you bring great
perspective John thank you that's great
perspective John your family's from
there and you want them drinking toxic
piss you're such a great man you are
such a wonderful Dude John Avalon
because it's the one year of Ukraine so
Biden's got to be there that line that
line the preeminent responsibility of
the president is to stop Russia
uh you guys would have to clarify this
but when they swear the president on the
uh on the Bible and they talk about the
Constitution all that is there anything
about stopping Russia or is it something
about protecting the rights of Americans
and yeah I can't remember all of it
right now you know what I mean
it's nonsense but they put that up there
and then I would imagine the average
clapping seal that watches CNN is like
oh my God it's right and he's from there
and he obviously likes toxic sludge and
ugh anyway this is what they do they
carry water for the machine if this was
reversed you really must understand this
guys again and I know you know it it's a
problem that I have that my audience is
bright most people have audiences that
are stupid so you have to explain
everything to them but as I keep saying
sometimes I think I can just kind of
look at you and you'll get what I'm
doing here already if this was reversed
and Trump was President right now and
there was you know and there was a war
in Russia first off everyone would be
blaming Trump for it right they'd say
this is because Trump is weak on Putin
and that's why he did it even though in
reality Putin did nothing for four years
he did a bunch of like take Crimea
under Obama did nothing under Trump now
he's back that that Trump's out but if
this was happening under Trump they'd be
telling you that Trump and Putin are in
cahoots and it's a horrific offensive
disaster that same guy John Avalon would
be on CNN saying I'm from East Palestine
and my relatives are drinking toxic
sludge and I blame orange man this is
what they do with everything but what
else do they do with everything they
racialize everything that's what they've
got to do so there was a clip this
weekend again from
CNN of actor Brian Christ Brian Cranston
he was he was the dentist in Seinfeld
what else was he in he was in Breaking
Bad that's the big one right and then he
was in Malcolm in the Middle or
something he wasn't either dad and
Malcolm in the Middle anyway he's an
actor and one of the things you need to
know about actors is they don't really
do anything they do something called
acting they pretend to do things and
then some of them are quite good at it
so you think they're doing the thing but
really what they are are just sort of
adult
aged children pretending to be on a
spaceship or pretending to be on an
island or pretending to sell meth but
they don't really do those things I
would imagine some of them sell that
anyway here he is talking to Chris
Wallace on CNN about Maga and racism and
you know black people shouldn't be happy
in this country because it's terrible
how did we get to a point where we
treated other human beings as slaves and
and we're okay with that when I when I
see the the make America great again
my comment is
do you do you do you accept that that
could possibly be construed as a racist
remark and most people a lot of people
go how could that be racist make America
great again I said so just ask yourself
from from an African-American experience
when was it ever great in America for
the African-American
when was it great
so if you're making it great again it's
not including them
so it's it's to teach us in the woke
world to open up and and accept the
possibilities that our privilege has
created blind spots for us and maybe I
haven't seen what is really happening
yet in all my years oh Brian Cranston in
the woke world you pathetic pandering
buffoon first off America is the least
racist nation in the history of the
world that is why black people white
people Asian people and all sorts of
other people still want to come here and
still nobody leaves America has been
quite good to everyone despite historic
injustices you know we did we fought a
civil war literally brothers killing
brothers uncles killing nephews to end
slavery and that this clown Brian
Cranston that he thinks he's so much
better than George Washington right
because how could we get to this point
when humans own slave slaves you know
that slavery was the way of the world
and the United States in the last 200
plus years was the country that really
ended it quicker than anybody else that
African nations were selling slaves to
other Africans black people selling
slaves to black people and there's still
slavery in the modern world see what's
going on in parts of the Middle East and
how they built that world cup thing in
Qatar
um
but he how could we do this how could we
do this how sure imagine he thinks he's
better than George Washington he
literally thinks he's better than George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson you
pandering woke World buffoon if you
really believe that give up all your
money give up all your money never take
another acting gig Brian Cranston there
is no gig that you're doing in acting
that a black man can't do and you're
just in the way for that black man so
why are you so racist Brian Cranston
give a good young black actor your
residual payments for being Dr
on Seinfeld doctor what the uh Tim
Whatley thank you figured it out got it
on my own before you could even Google
it
you were in Seinfeld for about four
episodes as Tim Whatley okay you know
what you did as Tim Whatley you were a
Christian who converted to Judaism for
the jokes you owe the Jews okay
these people are just absolutely
ridiculous but I'm showing you that not
even to make fun of Bryan Cranston who
cares about another just actor that's
stupid and woke like you guys get that
this is how the mainstream media pushes
these narratives on people endlessly
what's the other one they're really
pushing on people well it's that Florida
is racist and our governor is racist and
everyone here is racist I was with the
governor this weekend for a couple day
education conference the Florida
blueprint uh event and I didn't hear
anything about racism or anything that
would be construed as racism I heard
about how we could teach kids how not
indoctrinate them I heard things of that
nature but I did not hear oh we don't
like black people or something like that
uh here's video of cbs's Michelle Miller
suggesting that Florida is Banning books
that have black characters in them hint
it's not true
an important footnote to the story
soulway has been banned in some Florida
schools and might be banned Statewide
under the stop woke act Harrison says
it's disappointing and upsetting but she
will continue to work on stories with
diverse characters the fact that soulway
a character trying to find her identity
and be okay with it would be banned
because she's a black character she just
couldn't believe it but these are
stories for everyone when she was
describing big I was like oh my God I
wish that had existed when I was a kid I
love that story
love the vibrancy of the work I mean it
just jumps off the page yeah
God and that white guy my God I'm going
to keep my job because it jumps off the
page I'm white I'm hanging on by a
thread over here unless I say something
patterning so of course
it is not true what they just said there
are a little context let's give you some
context uh Solway the book Banning it
appears that and this is according to
Yahoo news that none of the books have
been banned but some books have been
temporarily pulled while they are
reviewing some of this literature right
because there's also all of these books
where they are literally teaching fourth
graders how to give hand jobs which is
generally not thought of as a good thing
if you want a little more context about
what Solway actually is uh It Is by
Lupita nyungo and vashti Harrison it's a
children's book about colorism and
self-esteem a dark-skinned Kenyan girl
named Solway which means star wishes she
had lighter skin like her sister until a
magical journey changes her life and
helps her see beauty okay so I don't
know everything about the freaking book
but Brian Griffin who is uh Governor
desantis's press secretary well here's
what he had to say about it America
here's Michelle Miller lying to your
face on CBS with zero accountability
from her co-hosts or network no book in
Florida is banned Statewide this is the
official representative of this anthis
and no book would be permissibly removed
from a classroom for having a black
character they want you to be
misinformed so do you see how they do
this what they're really trying to make
this sound like if you watch the clip
that we just played it's somehow it's
because she's black and they don't want
you hearing about a black character in a
book they are looking into some books to
see has critical race Theory leaked into
this stuff has this genderqueer lunacy
leaked into this stuff are they teaching
neo-racism to kids so they are looking
into some things which actually is I
would say at this point if you believe
in State education at any level and I
think there's a good debate to have
there whether we should have public
schools at all anymore but if you
believe that they should then the state
has to decide well what is appropriate
for kids so they're looking into some
things uh Chris Ruffo from the Manhattan
Institute who you guys know he's been on
the show a few times he's helping Ron
DeSantis clean up some of this stuff
here in Florida and he's going to be
working at new school on the west coast
on the board over there to really help
get die out of whatever institutions
remain in Florida he had a tweet
relative to what's going on here in
terms of the Dei the diversity Equity
inclusion bureaucracy related to the
administration he said Biden's new
executive order creating a national
diversity equity and inclusion
bureaucracy has a special mandate for
woke AI the order instructs the federal
government to protect the public from
algorithmic disinformation and to deploy
AI systems in a manner that Advance
Equity do you understand that before I
read the specific part there
the a manner that Advance Equity Equity
is counter to all of our founding
documents which were are about equality
we cannot guarantee that everyone ends
up in the same spot the best we can do
is give you an even playing field and
hope and with the little hard work that
you're going to figure it out for for
yourselves so look at section B here the
red highlighted box when designing
developing and acquiring acquiring and
using artificial intelligence and
automated systems in the federal
government agencies shall do so
consistent with applicable laws in a
manner that advances Equity guys do you
understand this is like Terminator 2
Skynet stuff if Skynet had turned on and
instead of trying to kill all the people
and all the Terminators getting out
there trying to kill John Connor if
basically they had just the machines had
turned on and they started walking into
offices and taking out all the white
Executives and basically making it so
that the exact proportion of white
people to uh black people to Asian
people to gay people people to trans
people to PLA and the Terminators would
force us to do all of that Equity is
against the American experiment Equity
is is socialism and communism on
steroids okay uh the idea that they are
are designing government computer
systems using AI
you can see man you could really see it
it's like if you if you think that big
Tech has not been bad enough well wait
till woke AI has taken over and we've
talked about it a little bit on the show
it's already completely infected chat
GPT I mean there's there's huge problems
here so what are the solutions you know
that we here at the Reuben report we
like Solutions we need Solutions in
terms of the government in terms of the
media in terms of these multinational
corporations before they kill us
basically because they're turning on
Skynet they're putting diseases out
there
they don't like us and we don't like
them so what do we do we actually just
have to make sure that this machine is
starved so Ron DeSantis and by the way I
said I would say it uh on the show on
Thursday or Friday I said if I got any
uh Insider information about him running
I would tell you on the show today I did
not I did not there were a bunch of
congressmen and Senators there which was
interesting uh some of the people that
were at the event that I was at included
Kim Reynolds who's the governor of uh
Iowa there was a Ron Johnson senator
from Tennessee Thomas Massey from
Kentucky was there chip Roy was there it
was actually the more right-leaning Mike
Lee senator from Utah it was the more
right-leaning people so it's kind of
funny because Trump's been going off
onto Santa's he's a rhino globalist but
all of the people at the conference that
we were at
they were all like the Liberty people
the the true right-wing Freedom people
so that argument is probably not going
to work for Trump he's gonna have to
move on that one but anyway what do you
do you starve the Beast you actually get
rid of this permanent State this endless
bureaucratic control of all of our lives
and that's exactly what Ron DeSantis is
planning look at like all these
entrenched bureaucrats CDC NIH FD they
need to be cleaned out because they
totally failed uh and they're not
advocating for the best interests of the
people of this country it's been a total
disaster there's a proposal uh that I
think a lot of us wanted to see under
the prior Administration to to do a
schedule F so anybody that has any
policy role is classified as a schedule
F and they can be removed uh by the
president the the left would litigate
that but I honestly think we would win
on that in the Supreme Court and I also
think it's one thing to have some type
of job job rules for the the vows of the
bureaucracy like your supervisor what
they can do president United States has
Article 2 power who controls the
executive branch is it the elected
president or is it some bureaucrat in
the bowels of the bureaucracy that can't
be fired and so I think push needs to
come to shove on this but whoever gets a
majority of the Electoral College is has
the right to impose their agenda through
the executive branch right and what they
did with President Trump was basically
try to nullify the election through not
only bureaucratic intransigence but
malfeasance with the collusion hoax and
some of those things and so
reconstitutionalizing government starts
with reconstitutionalizing the executive
branch under article two you know why
that's so good it's because he's able to
tell you something that's true right
like what actually the powers of the
executive branch are and how they were
undermined when Trump was president but
he's able to explain it in a way that
shows his competency and and I would say
potentially what he might do if he was
to make it all the way to the White
House
um in essence what he's saying there it
is it started with Trump for sure like
drain the swamp he's saying these
bureaucrats they gotta go these people
who stay in government in DC Forever and
then we wonder why things always get
worse why budgets always get bigger why
the dollar always becomes worth less why
the machine is always growing well it's
because there is an entire system that
has been set up to never shrink but
there are ways I mean that's really what
he's saying about schedule up there are
ways to shrink it and if we don't we
will end up with a system that has
nothing to do with the system that our
Founders intended and our Founders were
big on an F word
Freedom they loved freedom and they
would be very disappointed if they saw
what was going on here today uh DeSantis
talked a bit about that to Mark Levin as
well you're conservative
what does that mean to you
well I think the foundation of it is
understanding uh the American project
our rights come from God not from the
government the founders rejected the
divine right of kings and it used to be
some people did have rights but it was a
courtesy of the state so that's not how
our system works we have these god-given
rights we loan power to the government
under a constitution to protect those
rights and I think that what we've seen
in more modern society is we've seen an
unmooring of those constitutional
foundations we have an administrative
state which is totally out of control it
violates people's freedoms it's really
been weaponized against factions of the
country that the ruling class doesn't
like and it's it we need to
reconstitutionalize uh this government
but but what we're facing now I think is
not what the founders intended in terms
of how this government should be
operating
he can explain it
and he gets it that is a competent and
and clear
explanation of what he sees government's
role is and perhaps again what his
future role might be so what do we do
with all of this well one of the things
is you can't just get out there and say
well here's how we were founded here's
what the right ideas are and gosh I do
hope that a whole bunch of people join
me on this adventure and why can't you
do that because right now we have a
media and big Tech system in place that
basically lies about everything as I
laid out today and we lay out on the
show every every day they lie about
everything and they make sure that a
certain amount of people will never know
the truth and when you never know the
truth and when you're in State education
and everything else you're going to
basically breed a generation of stupid
people
um to no fault of their own actually who
will always be dependent on the system
and they will always hear meaningless
slogans and applaud meaningless slogans
and they will be fearful of hard truths
and everything else uh so there are ways
to do this imagine if a president saved
this address but say Trump or whoever it
might be actually got in there and this
time and and even if it was Trump let's
not we don't have to make this all about
the sentence but imagine if Trump was
able to get in there this time and when
he was talking about draining the swamp
last I mean he just couldn't do it he
was overwhelmed by Bad actors and
leakers and everything else but imagine
if this time he came in with the
intention this is my number one goal
this is the biggest problem in America
we're going to blow this thing apart or
DeSantis did it right
things could start changing but you know
what we'd still we'd still need to build
new things because first off you can't
just blow away and and disassemble huge
parts of the government and and not
expect them to be replaced by something
but it's not that even if they went
ahead and did that you'd still need to
build new tech and New Media to make
sure the people understood what was
going on because if a trump or a
DeSantis go in there and they hack it
away they hack away at the Deep State
and they actually start firing
bureaucrats and they actually start
freeing the people and returning us back
to Freedom do you know what the
mainstream media will call it they will
call it Fascism and Nazism and
everything else so we need to build new
products to enable us to get the
messaging out and that's why and this is
a beautiful ending to Today's Show I am
so freaking proud of where I was for the
last couple days I was up in Longboat
Key which is right by Sarasota West
Coast of Florida where Rumble officially
opened their U.S headquarters I was at
the annual meeting I did a little talk
for some of the new employees I was at
the annual meeting last year when Rumble
had about 30 employees now we've got
about I think 120 or 140 employees the
company obviously subsequently went
public locals has offices in Miami
Rumble has offices in Sarasota we've got
tons of people who are who are employed
and now living in Florida tasting
Freedom enjoying the fruits of their
labor building building new pipes for
the internet literally we cut the blue
ribbon on Friday I had to leave at that
point because I was actually going to
West Palm to do this event with DeSantis
so also DeSantis couldn't be there but
he did send this congratulatory video
and I just wanted to play it for you
it's about a minute long hi I'm Governor
Ron DeSantis and I want to congratulate
all of you at Rumble as you open your
U.S headquarters here in Florida ever
since the big Tech censorship regime at
Google tried to silence me on YouTube my
official office has adopted Rumble as
our video sharing service of choice
because Rumble stands for freedom of
speech while the federal government has
failed to rein in the overreach of the
big Tech behemoths that you had Rumble
are taking on we will be protecting
Floridians with a digital Bill of Rights
to safeguard data privacy and we will
prohibit government agents from
coordinating with big Tech to police or
censor your speech for two years I've
been able to boycott Google YouTube
because Rumble has been there as a
backstop allowing us to speak truth when
others tried to shut us down so welcome
to the USA welcome to Florida and know
that you've got my business because you
believe in the importance of the First
Amendment and the freedom of speech that
we hold dear I have to say guys I I have
to kind of Pat myself on the back I try
not to do it that often here but I'm so
proud that I I built something in locals
that eventually merged with something
like Rumble to not only have these
Offices here but to be housed here and
to have a a governor and a system here
that is defending the very things that I
talk about every day in my life like
that is called
cohesion that that is you know those
those lines and those tracks in life you
know sometimes your professional life is
way ahead of your personal life or your
personal life's way ahead of your
professional life or your spiritual life
and what you're trying to do with as
many tracks as you have is to get them
to mostly line up and when I saw that
video I saw it a couple days ago for the
first time I was like man I know that
what I'm doing here is right and we are
fighting for the right things and we are
just going to keep fighting and I thank
you guys for being on that adventure
with us it is me Monday over at the
Reuben report locals Community here's
the one that I put up but this is this
is an oldie but a goodie I saw this one
originally probably a couple of years
ago but it just popped in to my feed
over the weekend and I thought we'd post
this one and you can see the Socialist
about to shoot the capitalist who is
actually keeping the board balanced then
he's going to go over the cliff be it
the actual Cliff or the fiscal cliff if
you want to join us a couple hundred
people have already put their memes in
uh go ahead post game show coming up
very shortly we've got a cold closed for
you a big week oh I'm interviewing the
governor today
how about that that's a nice ending to
this whole thing I'm interviewing the
I'm heading over to the local studio in
a little bit I'm interviewing the
governor in just a bit and a couple
other things so we'll keep you posted on
when we are posting that his book
actually comes out tomorrow so I think
we're going to touch on that a little
bit but I said to his guys you want me
to focus on the book and they said
actually focus on policy kind of tells
you everything you need to know about
the guy anyway we leave you with the uh
that lady pretending to be VP and we'll
be uh back with post game show in about
37 seconds adios every day Joe Biden and
I talk about and work together with our
partners
like former leader Hoyer current leader
lawyer
to lower the cost for the people of our
nation because you are a leader for
Working Families we have reduced Heating
and electricity bills
so folks have more money in their pocket
to buy things like school supplies
replace the dishwasher or take a family
vacation
[Music]
foreign